I changed I'm getting married I'm sorry
what did you say he's wonderful and
brilliant and we're getting married
there are some rumors of a third father
of the bride would you want to do a
third one of totally I would want to do
a three want to see it I would love to
see it um I heard a great storyline
Kieran Culkin's character comes back and
he's gay and he's having a gay wedding I
don't know if there's any truth to that
all right there is they haven't called
me yet it's hard to believe it has been
almost 25 years since Kimberly with her
wedding day sneakers start in the
original and you know she almost did an
audition but we can thank her mom Linda
who kind of convinced her to go for it
she wanted the best for me she pushed me
you know I always say she's that voice
in my head that still tells me to go for
it and do things that have adventures
and have parties and Linda actually
appears in the movie laughing next to a
movie mom Diane Keaton but today it is a
different story
Kimberly's mother her friend and biggest
cheerleader throughout her life now
suffers from dementia
Linda can't speak or write sometimes she
becomes violent and Kimberly made the
heart-wrenching decision to move her
into a home you know my mom was still
aware enough to know that she had just
been left and that was really horrible
your mom is nonverbal mm-hmm how hard is
it not to be able to talk to her every
day I think in many ways I've said
goodbye to the old mom
my brother said it's death by paper cut
small little there's another part of her
gone you know but Kimberly has found
strength in the face of the struggle and
she writes about it in her really moving
book where the light gets in there's joy
watching her son's play with it grandma
gratitude that her mom is still able to
have a sense of humor and laugh and
there's comfort knowing her husband
country star Brad Paisley is her rock
and her love no matter what he was there
on the really hard days um when I just I
didn't know what to do come just hold me
and let me cry anytime you go through
hard times and challenges in life and
you and you survive
it strengthens your relationships